Norman Ornstein co-author with John
makin of debt and taxes how America got
into its budget mess and what to do
about it where'd you get the idea for
this book this really arose years ago my
co-author John makin as an economist I'm
a political scientist we were talking
all the time we had offices right down
the hall from one another as we moved
into the 1980s about what made the zero
different was this really something
unique in American history as we began
to grapple with these deficits all the
time and was there a way that you could
pull an economist and a political
scientist who view the world in very
different ways with different expertise
is together to kind of look at the same
problem through a prism that we could
Forge and we began working on it mid
1980s and got into history in the more
we got into history the more if he got
bogged down and we also found we had
some divergent views and had to work all
of those through uh but we found that in
fact you can draw some lessons from both
professions and from the third
profession of history that are very
relevant and we found something that's
very difficult saying anything that's
new on this subject that hasn't been
said a million times before or won't be
said a million times again what's the
newest thing in the book well I think
there are a couple of things that are
new here the first is tying the history
to the contemporary side the second
though is some of the conclusions that
we come to and some of the suggestions
that we make because you really don't
want to do a book like this without
saying where do we go from here and
while it's not a detailed platform when
you look at this in historical terms you
step back and instead of just focusing
narrowly on whatever fixes you can make
and those fixes might be big things like
entitlement reform you step back and
think about the whole nature of the tax
system and you realize for example that
the way in which we have structured our
tax system didn't come about through
some conscious decision here's what we
want we want this mix of personal and
corporate income taxes of payroll taxes
of excise taxes and the like it didn't
arise out of ending grand plan it
rose out of circumstance and put us into
a mess frankly that I don't think
anybody anticipated or would have voted
for then you can step back and come up
with some solutions that may make some
sense when did you decide to become a
political scientist I decided at a young
age when I was in college but I was very
young in college I'd skipped a number of
grades and being young I really wasn't
terribly mature and didn't know what I
wanted to do with my life I started out
as a pre-med student and decided after a
couple of years that I just didn't have
that kind of motivation I thought about
law school but then i looked at lawyers
and decided that that really wasn't what
i wanted to do with my life and i was at
university Minnesota I had some teachers
there a huge school but with a unique at
least I found closeness in the political
science department and people who seem
to have interesting lives and live the
kind of lifestyle that I thought would
be interesting and worthwhile and I
found some excitement and one of my
professors had been in Washington for a
year as a congressional fellow of the
American Political Science Association
he talked about his experiences and tie
them to his teaching and that really
energized me and so I decided to go to
graduate school in political science who
was that what was his name was Jean
edinburg and he after being in
Washington went to the university
Minnesota to teach did some
administrative things there went to the
University of Illinois at Chicago circle
and then came back to Washington in the
Carter Administration as a senior
official at hgw then and then moved to
be secretary of the cabinet later to be
a top official the Democratic National
Party and then went into business and is
now a major figure with mci of all
things so he's led a very interesting
life where are you from i was born in
Grand Rapids Minnesota not Michigan I
often will have people call me and say
there's a typographical error on your
resume but Grand Rapids Minnesota which
was the birthplace of Francis gum later
Judy Garland that's what it's known for
in northern Minnesota and I moved around
a lot as a kid my father
there was a traveling salesman and we
took it all seriously he was from Canada
we lived in Canada for some years but I
basically grew up in the Twin Cities of
minnesota went to the University of
Minnesota and then went on to ann arbor
university michigan for graduate school
what year did you get out of the
University of 1967 how long have you
been in Washington totally well I came
to Washington after two years in
graduate school at Michigan in 1969 and
worked as a congressional fellow after a
gene iden berg had taught turned me on
to Washington from his experience as a
congressional fellow I set that as a
goal I came here and spent the year I
went back to Ann Arbor and finished my
dissertation my PhD dissertation then I
went off to teach in Italy at Johns
Hopkins School of Advanced International
Studies in Bologna for a year and came
back here in 1972 to teach at Catholic
University and basically except for a
year in Stanford at the Center for
Advanced Study and behavioral sciences
I've been here ever since what's a
political scientist a very good question
probably a technical terms that somebody
with a PhD in political science but it's
really I would define a political
scientist as somebody who tries to look
at political events and political
patterns and draw some perspectives some
generalizations some broad framework
some theory out of them you don't have
to be an academic necessarily to do that
but what would distinguish a political
scientist from say simply the myriad of
political analysts that we have around
Washington including a vast number who
are democratic analysts a Republican
analysts some of whom are pollsters some
of whom work in campaigns others of whom
just write or journalists that sense of
historical perspective the attempt to
try and take events and put them into a
generalizable state is what would
distinguish people like me or my
colleague Tom man at the Brookings
Institution who came here at the same
time as I did and others from the
general pack I think you said as we
opened up here that there was
time when you skip the number of grades
yeah how did you do that it was as much
moving around from place to place as
anything else but in the end I fourth
and fifth grades together I took ninth
and tenth grades together i took
eleventh and twelfth grades together I
ended up effectively graduating from
high school at the age of fourteen and
from college at the age of 18 would you
recommend that to someone you know in
some ways I'm better off for it but in
other ways I wouldn't recommend it for
for another person there's an awful lot
of stress and strain and social stress
and strain that comes that comes along
with that you know a greater too if
you're finding that you want to stay
intellectually challenged can can be
alright but my time in high school
especially involve some real strains
when I had friends who were driving and
and I wasn't and then you you also have
to confront the reality later in life
when you're no longer the Boy Wonder
hello how old are you now 45 and I'm
anything but a boy one day you like
politicians yes I don't like all
politicians but I admire and respect
politicians as a class that puts me in
the distinct minority in this country
and I very much recognize it I am NOT a
politician I've spent my life a large
part of it around them I am a strong
believer in the political process that
we have in this country that our framers
set out I believe basically that no
democracy functions without politics as
both the kind of oil that keeps things
moving along and the kind of glue that
holds things together there's an awful
lot including a lot of tradition in this
country that's part of what made this
country great that has disdain for
politics and it makes this country great
because we get our distance from anybody
in positions of power and we make sure
that they don't get pretenses that
they're better than the rest of us
that's all to the good but it can be
taken too far and in my judgment uh
politics and
politicians are required to make things
happen a lot of what they do we are
going to like very much you know the old
saw that you should never watch laws or
sausages being made is there as an adage
for a reason there's no question about
that there's no question that the more
we have seen with this remarkable level
of disclosure that we have in the system
now which is by and large a terrific
phenomenon nevertheless it's gotten
people enraged about the nature of the
political process and it's taken the
profession politician and turned it into
something that is just about as dirty in
the society at large and in the press
conception of it combined with that as
anything that we have and that
de-stresses me frankly there's no
question people do wrong things and they
should be punished for doing wrong
things but there are an awful lot of
people who are street politicians in in
this country and Tip O'Neill was one who
wouldn't shrink from that term who
really have been great figures in my
judgment do you have someone in history
or some more than one that you really
admire there are politicians throughout
the course of history that I admire I
admire James Madison just looking back
at the dynamic by which the Constitution
was put together he may not have been a
great president but he was just an
absolutely a central figure in
understanding the dynamics of this
system and giving us something that
really has been great in my judgment I
really admire others of the framers I
didn't admire Alexander Hamilton much
frankly before I got into this I didn't
know as much I hadn't read much about
Hamilton and he really is the most
distant I think of the major figures in
the framing period but I came to admire
him enormously as I read different
biographies and aspects of him I'd
admire Jefferson enormously although
some of his conceptions of society were
a little bit removed the celebration of
the rural life I think wouldn't fit as
well today but as a historic figure
enormously and then looking back frankly
through the course of history
people who have used politics to make
things happen there's a book that dick
cheney wrote with his wife Lynne some
years ago and dick is a political
scientist went to the University of
Wisconsin came to Washington as a
congressional fellow in fact the year
before I did he made something of
himself and his wife is a historian they
wrote a book called kings of the hill
looking at all of the major powerful
speakers throughout history and you read
this book which is a wonderfully written
book and it brought a lot to life for me
there are speakers Nicholas Longworth
just to take one example who wheel deal
made things happen and we would view
them with disdain today many would I
don't if I had one hero i think and
throughout the course of American
politics though it would be Sam Rayburn
who combined it seems to me the best of
idealism and pragmatism of trying to do
the right thing and doing what was
necessary to make things happen of
having a concept of what his role was
that was it just an extraordinarily
important one during the course of
American history do you have a personal
political ideology yeah we all do but I
try and I think without the success that
you do Brian but I try I tried to carve
out a role for myself that is not a one
that has an ax to grind I'm fairly
visible in this in the political process
I do a lot of television I do a lot of
commentary a lot of writing there are a
lot of people who do who are the
Democratic Party analyst or the
Republican analyst and I've tried to
avoid that and instead carve out a less
of a subjective ideological or partisan
role I try to step back and analyze and
take a viewpoint but not one that works
to the benefit of any particular party
I'm not always successful and certainly
people think I have a particular point
of view although often times they're
very wrong but that's the role that I
decided I want to fill and so I don't
contribute to campaigns I don't get
involved in any kind of partisan things
I'll go and speak to whichever partisan
group wants me to speak to them but
without putting any kind of a tilt on it
American Enterprise Institute book
that's what this book yes it's all about
won't show the audience what we're
talking about here that's known in some
circles as a conservative think tank
does that give it difficulty to you and
is it a conservative thing uh you know
everybody tries to put labels on things
and there's no question that if you I
suppose if you took the viewpoints of
every one of the 45 to 50 scholars and
fellows at AEI as it's known added them
up and then took an average you'd
probably find that it was somewhere over
to the right of center and probably if
you took the partisan affiliation of the
people there you'd find that there were
more Republicans than anything else but
just like a university AEI has a range
of viewpoints and especially across a
whole set of issues and just to take one
example the president of the American
Enterprise Institute christum youth is
very strongly for term limits I'm very
strongly against term limits we've had
debates among ourselves we have a number
of people who are very much identified
with the Democratic Party a lot of
people who don't have a partisan
affiliation the Brookings Institution is
known as a liberal think tank but in
some areas there they have had people
who are more conservative than than we
have had and who are more Republican so
I think it's probably not wise to pick
the glib label now the American
Enterprise Institute has a motto which
is roughly the competition of ideas is
central to a free society and it
basically behind it is the notion that
markets work that markets everywhere
work and that you want to put your
stress on markets and that's true in the
economic sphere as it's true in the
sphere of ideas and the world of ideas
and I believe that and I think most of
the people at AEI basically believe that
and that's if there's a philosophical
framework
it's it's that I find some people assume
that I must be a conservative if I'm at
the American Enterprise Institute and it
in some ways that works to my
disadvantage in other ways it works to
my advantage because I will often say or
write things that go against the grain
of what contemporary observers would
view as conservative or liberal although
some of those things opposition to term
limits for example I would view as
classically conservative but just
doesn't fit the contemporary notion but
in some ways it just keeps people from
having a real firm sense of where I am
politically or ideologically it keeps
them from being able to pigeonhole me
and that's just fine as far as I'm
concerned you say in the acknowledgments
of this book that the task was daunting
what did you mean trying to develop
generalizations out of the budget
process the fiscal process the political
process the economic system over 200
years and come up with any conclusions
was daunting trying frankly to write in
300 pages or so what is an economic
history of some of these issues and
we're not historians was daunting as
well and also daunting was getting
somebody with a different point of view
and a different background and making
sure that we could write it together and
put both of our names on it co-authoring
a book sometimes is a whole lot harder
than writing it yourself what are you
and John making disagree about the most
well I think I i hate to characterize
John's views exactly but you know John
is Johnson economist who has some
sympathise with the supply-side kind of
movement although I wouldn't pitch and
hold him and he wouldn't pigeonhole
himself either there was a time along
the way especially in the late 1980s mid
to late 1980s when I was more concerned
about the impact of deficits than he was
uh and when we had very different
viewpoints in terms of what to do
in policy terms we probably have a
different partisan perspective as well
but it's not it's not a dramatic clash I
mean this is not one person at this end
of the spectrum and another person at
the other end of the spectrum coming
together it's much more just viewing
stressing things a little bit
differently John comes out of the
University of Chicago as an economist he
has the kind of distinctive viewpoint
that the University of Chicago
represents choose which is more of a
stress on monetary policy for example
than on fiscal policy also when I look
at the way in which we play out economic
policy I instinctively look to the
dynamics of the political process uh
when I look for example at the impact of
various constitutional amendments or
some of the structural changes that
might be brought to bear I first focus
on how the political process will
channel those things through distort
them create unintended consequences he
looks at the economic impact you write
about the balanced budget amendment you
read about the line-item veto word where
do you come down on both of those
against it's basically what you see if
you look at the course of American
history is that structure can make a
difference in fact if you look at the
last few years they pay as you go
provisions that were built into the 1990
budget agreement the so-called hard
freeze no increase even for inflation on
the discretionary part of the budget
that was built into 1993 are actually
having a serious effect on the budget
much more than some of the other
structural changes like Graham Rudman
which was tried in the mid 1980s but any
notion that you can come up with some
panacea by changing the Constitution or
the structures we think is just wrong uh
it's it is a political and economic
process joined together and you can't
force behavior in a democratic political
system where you have a public that
basically wants more services to be
provided and they want to pay less for
them you have to work through the
dynamics of a political process to make
that happen both of us also and I
suspect
eat more than John really hesitate
before going to the Constitution to
bring about changes that that's a
nuclear solution and the course of
American history would suggest that you
don't make those changes lightly you
don't make them without recognizing that
you can have a profound effect with
unintended consequences and it's
something that you can't reverse very
easily so you don't go into it without
recognizing those things and we would
not go into it have you ever thought
about running for office years ago I
thought about running for office but I
haven't thought about that for many many
years even though I spent a lot of time
with politicians and around the
political process and I am immersed in
some ways in the political process and I
think I have a very good understanding
for and feel for the political process I
like the role that I play it gets a
little embarrassing for me sometimes a
little uncomfortable for me because one
of the things that I've also done over
the years is to try and devote some time
to encouraging people to go into public
service I was one of the founders of the
National Commission on public service
that Paul Volcker chaired and on its
board and I remain very active in that
area and that means not just people into
elective office but into a point of
office or even into service of another
form I'm very concerned that we've
created all kinds of barriers a real
formal and informal to good people even
being encouraged to spend time in those
things I crusade to get them out there
but the reality at this point is when I
look at the climate generally and the
barriers that we've created I wouldn't
do it right now and I'd have a hard time
encouraging somebody else to do it right
now that de-stresses me but it keeps me
from considering any kind of bid for
office if someone were to follow you
around on most days what would a day be
like there isn't a real typical day
Brian but I suppose if you try to meld
together a week and then draw a typical
day out of it there'd be a couple of
hours on the
mostly with journalists I spent a lot of
time with journalists and I've been
caricatured in the past for all of the
time that I spend with journalists and
the quotes that are used but I find that
it's very useful I try to do in part
frankly because I think journalists
these days especially often have no
sense of historical perspective or
context and the stories that they write
and I really try and help provide some
of that you get people coming on to a
beat who just don't know what's been
done before or where this fits in and
that's required and I'll often spend
time with journalists showing them
things to read or trying to give them a
little bit of an education we're from
your office at AEI yeah mostly for my
own go there every day that's my basin
on there when I'm in town that's where I
go in the morning and i also find
frankly that when i talk to journalists
there's a feedback there too i learn an
awful lot because there are people out
there on the ground I'm up on Capitol
Hill on an average day once or twice a
day I may be giving a talk I might be
having lunch with somebody with one of
the members of the House or Senate or a
staff person or I might be just up
nosing around trying to find things out
it's really required I'm on the road a
fair amount I do a lot of lecturing in
town and around the country and that
would occupy a fair amount of time and
some of that time I spend with
journalists or others is at pay phones
at the airport as well as you know
they've been articles written about you
as America's spokesman that when they
want the soundbite they come to norm
Ornstein how did that start now let me
say that you're America's spokesman so
I'm not although not with not with the
point of view but that started I guess
around the early 1980s you know I'd come
to this town on a regular enduring
full-time basis in 1972 to teach at
Catholic University I taught there for
about 13 years and then I developed an
association with the American Enterprise
Institute part time in nineteen seventy
eight or so continued but
the first time I arrived I started to
write not just for scholarly journals or
books for the scholarly audience or the
college audience but also write
newspapers and magazines op-ed pieces or
uh analyses and I started at a fairly
early stage to do some television mostly
public television early on uh commentary
and analysis on when the Watergate
hearings were going on and all the other
things that Public Television back then
with Paul Duke and Jim Lehrer were doing
and started to do some things with
McNeal errors soon as the show got
started and I get quoted a lot uh as
time passed I get quoted more often by
journalists in part because so much was
happening in the political process from
the mid-1970s on reforms were going all
over the place you had Watergate he had
dramatic change we had the Pietschmann
of the president we had a new present
coming in and then a change of party in
1976 and so on and with all of those
things you had many more journalists
coming to Washington and more of a
Washington focus looking for something
to let me know you know there are a lot
of people on this town that they can do
what you do yeah why what is it did you
ever analyzed your own yeah they own
reasons why they started quoting you yes
I think there were a couple of reasons
one reason was I'd return my phone calls
I was here in town that's another reason
but I decided for better or for worse
right after I'd come here in part
because as a young academic trying to do
my own research into interviews you know
I'd call up major figures and politics
or journalism sometimes they get back to
me other times I just couldn't get
through and i found that frustrating and
I said look I will always return my
phone calls it's a matter of decency and
politeness so calls would come in from
whatever place whatever newspaper or new
service or journalists and I try make a
point every day as I was a round of
returning every phone call well what I
discovered was that for reporters uh you
know they place all kinds of calls some
would get return some never would in the
sense that even if you came from States
news service or a smaller newspaper that
you get a call return that helped turned
out I got criticized
for that as a being a hungry to get my
name in the papers but I did that
another thing that made a difference i
believe is that the natural tendency of
an academic somebody who spends his or
her life teaching and doing research is
not to be concise but to speak in almost
50 minute segments you prepare a lecture
its a 50 minute period you have a thesis
or a point to make and you expand it to
fill 50 minutes at the same time you are
trained not to go out on a limb not to
make flat statements but to couch them
in shades of grey because that's the way
the world works as a social scientist
especially so it's an exaggeration but
not much to say that you could call up
many academics and start by saying well
what's your name and you'd get a
50-minute discourse on the background
and history of of the name that was a
tendency that I had gone away from
partly when I started to write for
newspapers you find that the discipline
required to write a 750 word column is
much greater than if you're writing a
scholarly article where there is no
particular length you have to come to
the point you have to have a thesis and
then you have to support it so I would
speak plainly to people and where there
was a desire especially back at a time
when he had a flooded journalist coming
to Washington who hadn't spent time here
before to get a perspective that could
give a little bit of history and
background and they turned to a lot of
people in the academic world and find
that they just couldn't get answers and
I would give answers and so I got quoted
a lot and what happens of course is if
you get quoted then journalists will say
to others you know I need to talk to
somebody on this story and they'd say
call him he'll return your call he'll
give you what you need and then after a
period of time it became electronic
people would write stories they'd go to
the Nexus or other computerized
databases and they'd see who'd been
quoted on previous stories of that sort
and so I get quoted more and more and
then I got a couple of profiles done as
the quote/unquote king of quotes or king
of the soundbite the same thing happens
with
television and that suddenly became a
persona it left me a little
uncomfortable frankly it's you know
everybody likes to get some attention
but if the attention that you get is not
about the serious work that you do but
about the notion that you're simply gliv
and you can throw off a clever 9-second
burst or a six-word quote that's not
really the way you want to become known
if you ever said to yourself I want to
put words in your mouth so but when
somebody you see somebody coming at you
with a camera and they they've talked to
you on the phone about an issue and you
know what they want you say I know
exactly how to say it in 10 seconds and
it's going to end up in this piece yes
there's no question that you start to do
these things after a while and you know
either when you've said it or before
you've said it what it is that's going
to be there I found interestingly what
paid a difference for me there is when I
spent time on the other side of the
camera back now about 10 years ago I did
a 26 part television series on Congress
was done in conjunction with the
American political science association
and weta the public television station
here in Washington for use on public
television it was broadcast but it was
also used in the classroom a sort of
telecourse a full course for credit
Edwin Newman formerly of NBC was the
host and I was his co-host and went out
did a lot of pieces and I would sit in
the chair that you're now sitting in and
interview people and then go back with
the producers and try and edit the
pieces to try and fit whether it was a
show on committees or committee
assignments or the role of outside
groups and I'd see the frustration that
often would come to the television
reporter when you'd ask somebody a
question and you know as you've worked
up the script you only had maybe five
minutes out of a 30-minute show to do a
piece on one particular area and you
would have some film to use and then
you'd want to turn to somebody saying
something and you try to extract a
comment that was to the point usable and
also had somebody looking at you instead
of looking all over the place and
speaking like this instead of going up
and down and up and down and you'd begin
to see what the constraints were on
people doing these sorts of things and
that helped what I found though frankly
over the years is that I'll do less of
that I can't return all my phone calls
anymore just as an example I had to go
out to San Francisco last week to give a
speech and with the time changing
everything I got out there and it was
after the close of business and I had
maybe 20 messages and then the next day
I spoke in the morning and then flew
back and got back late in the evening
and I could return a couple of calls but
basically i had another 20 messages or
so or 25 and the next day I had work to
do so I don't return the phone calls I
found that to do all the television that
people were asking me to do meant that I
take sometimes 20 minutes or a half an
hour to do an interview in which six or
seven words would get used and often
frankly those six or seven words are
entirely bunnell or trite there a bridge
in and what's there for what you get out
of it it's not worth the time and effort
and if you're going to get criticized
for being on television too much what's
the point so I pick and choose a little
bit more the other thing that I found
has happened frankly is that some of the
early pieces that were done of me were
trying to use me as a way of critiquing
the press the idea was that journalists
go in packs they all quote the same
people they're too lazy to develop their
own sources or to go outside the norm
and what they really want to do is to
express their own point of view and so
they'll get somebody who will do that
for them and then have that as a kind of
disguise well I found that when most of
these stories were done around nineteen
seventy eight or eighty or 82 that
didn't happen to me very much mostly
when journalists would call me it was
because they really didn't know where to
start on a story and I helped provide
some structure framework suggest even
people that they could talk to or some
of the historical analogies and it was
worth it to spend that time or a
television reporter would come to me
maybe a story on Congress or a story on
an issue that related to what Congress
was doing who hadn't done it before been
assigned it and I could help structure a
story or provide some perspective and
then the quid pro quo implicit was well
we'll use you a little bit in this piece
so none of that would show up on the air
but I knew it had been provided but
these days frankly more and more I do
see the kind of laziness that's there I
do see that often reporters will come
and all they want they've already
written a story is some quote to bolster
it and I don't want any part of that
frankly I don't see any particular
reason to get into that kind of of an
exchange so I do less of it this book
was written was anyone in particular in
mind well the hope was that it would
reach a larger audience it's never going
to reach the audience of Michael
Crichton or the kinds of bestsellers in
fiction or nonfiction that other books
will books about economics books about
history books that get into some detail
aren't going to do that but the hope was
that this would reach an audience that
went beyond the academic or the expert
and budget or tax policy to a larger lay
audience really frankly the c-span
audience of people who have an interest
in public affairs who watch these issues
you know the title debt and taxes is
obviously supposed to be a little bit
clever playing on the notion of death
and taxes but you look at what's
happened with the debates over the
budget the debates over taxes the
debates over health care over the
deficits that we have and a natural
reaction is going to be I don't
understand any of this and so the hope
was you could reach people who really
have an interest in public affairs and
have a little bit of facility with some
of these issues but not a lot and give
them something that will provide them
that perspective some sense of history
some sense of what's happened in the
last decade what makes it unique what
makes it fit with the rest of what's
been going on and also some kind of a
blueprint for where we might go from
here what
you say that person that says this
country is going down the tubes because
of debt and taxes uh you can offer a
more hopeful message although not a
Pollyanna SH message either we've got a
problem we have several problems and the
fact is we're not going to get out of
them with a wave of a magic wand or in a
short period of time we have dug
ourselves a hole there's no question
there's no question if you look over 200
years we've dug holes throughout that
period of time but we've always dug our
way out of them is this the biggest hole
we've ever been in it's not the biggest
we've ever been in the biggest we've
ever been in came after the Second World
War and the fact is if you look at the
kind of crushing debt we had after the
Revolutionary War a crushing debt we had
after the civil war first world war the
Second World War we've had enormous
debts built up over short periods of
time but always in the past when we
built up large debt it came with a war
or it came with a serious economic
devastation depression at least then
when we moved to peace and prosperity we
built our way out of it we've had a
history of going into debt and then
getting out of debt what makes this
period disturbing is we've gotten into
debt without the major war without the
economic depression and we built in
structural things that make it difficult
now that's the downside the upside is
we've begun to show serious discipline
and a recognition of the problem and
we're moving towards a period of
economic growth that well probably if we
can continue to show the same kind of
discipline and indeed focus on areas of
the budget where we haven't shown that
discipline move out of the jam and it's
not that we have to get into a situation
where we have a balanced budget or a
surplus to get out of the jam we need to
move the debt level down to a point
where deficits are manageable given our
enormous wealth in this country how do
we compared with the other big countries
in the world when it comes to the debt
you know it's interesting because if you
you you have to look at debt not in
salute terms but in relative terms I
mean let's face it if you or i had a
two-million-dollar mortgage say which is
after all debt most individuals have
debt with their mortgages it would be
crushing if Jay Rockefeller had a
two-million-dollar mortgage it doesn't
mean as much or if Bill Gates they had a
Microsoft with seven billion dollars had
it so it's relative so you look at debt
as a share of the gross domestic product
the GDP what we used to call the GNP
gross national product in a country and
what you find is we are not out of the
norm of most of the Western
industrialized democracies and indeed
there are other countries Japan among
them that have had a much higher debt
much more of a leveraged aspect to
things now that doesn't mean that
they're worse off than we are because in
a country like Japan for example they
have had a savings rate in the private
sector so much greater than ours that
the money has been there to help finance
that debt but now they're beginning to
discover the perils of keeping up that
kind of a debt as their economy falters
and they no longer have the kind of
savings rate that they had before and
we're beginning to show signs of greater
discipline now what about the tax side
of things how do we compare with other
countries on text uh contrary to the
conventional wisdom compared to
virtually every other Western democracy
Western industrialized democracy we have
lower taxes most other Western
industrialized democracies have much
more extensive social welfare systems
funded through the government than we do
that doesn't mean that we should emulate
them and you can see from their economic
and social problems in many cases that
they're going to try and move more to
emulate us and that doesn't mean that we
shouldn't have even more discipline in
terms of what we do with taxes but we
are a lower tax society then most others
are of course that's always been our
economic strength that we have not moved
as rapidly or as wholeheartedly towards
having government tick off major chunks
of
the running of the society as other
countries have we've moved in that
direction as they all have but a little
more slowly and much more reluctantly
this book sells for $25 put out by x
books yep which is a unit of Random
House whatwhat's how many books like
this would be so you think uh our hope
and expectation at least is that will
sell 20,000 25,000 book something of
that sort and it could go higher how
many books have you written in the past
uh it's complicated in some ways it
depends on how you define them but it's
it's up around eight or nine that
includes books of which I've had major
contributions but edited and a couple of
others where I've been co-authors and
how did you break up the book and with
your co-author originally which is a few
years ago we each took chapters and
wrote graphs of chapters but as times
past as time passed we'd end up sending
the chapters back and forth running them
through both of our word processors to a
point where now frankly with a couple of
exceptions there are a couple of
chapters there that are that are much
more distinctively the product of one or
the other of us most of them would be
very hard for me to go through now and
figure out which section was mine in
which section was John's he's write a
lot about Alexander Hamilton and Thomas
Jefferson that you talked about the
first of this program parties are there
where would Alexander Hamilton feel the
happiest today and where we don us Jeff
erson feel that if to paraphrase I think
it was Yogi Berra if Hamilton and
Jefferson were alive today they'd be
spinning in their graves I be very hard
for them to figure out where to go
because of course the reality is that
Jefferson's view of the society and the
role of government was that the ideal
society was an agrarian society was one
where people were closer to the soil
closer to the roots he had an enormous
affection for the average person the
working person the downtrodden and grey
dastak distrust of elites governmental
elites economic elites and others and
believe that a concentration of power in
the hands of those elites was something
to be avoided so he didn't want
government to get very large and he
didn't want to put a lot of focus on the
major industrial elements the large
factories or others in the society
Alexander Hamilton was much more of a
Royalist he loved being around elites he
was an elitist himself he believed in a
very strong and powerful government he
certainly had a strong bent towards an
executive and the executive branch but
he also believed in a highly activist
role for government Hamilton saw debt as
one of the great engines of growth and
prosperity in a country if you managed
it appropriately and that you could
create the kind of mercantilist activist
economy and society that would reach out
and play a strong role in the rest of
the world by managing that debt
Jefferson hated debt because the more
you got into debt the more government
played a role the more had to tax the
more it would become a larger force in
society now put that together with today
Jefferson is the hero of the Democratic
Party why is he the hero of course all
around the country the Democratic Party
throws these Jefferson Jackson day
dinners because he stood with the
average person the working person the
poor person but his distaste for
government his sense that you want to
avoid a major government role at
virtually all costs would be right up
the alley of Ronald Reagan who in that
sense was very much a Jeffersonian
Alexander Hamilton has been a hero of
the Republicans and these days although
it's changing a little bit but you go
through the reagan-bush years when you
had Republicans dominating the executive
and the Hamiltons notion of a strong and
assertive executive you know very much a
Republican idea there was that element
that they liked very much and of course
they also liked the idea that he stood
with business especially as we would
define it today but the notion of a
powerful federal government
is something that conservatives today
Republicans would move away from and in
effect what you have is each of them has
a distinctive character and we still see
it in the way in which we debate these
issues in society but we have a meld a
blend of their qualities in different
politicians if you look at Ronald Reagan
he has a Jeffersonian philosophy but he
wanted to use Hamiltonian means grabbing
onto that power to make it happen he was
very much an activist president very
much along the lines frankly of Franklin
Roosevelt there's an awful lot of
similarity between the two of them and
the way in which they approach the use
of government Bill Clinton is in some
ways a Jeffersonian at least in terms of
his attachment to the downtrodden and
the poor but also is very much a
Hamiltonian in terms of his activist
approach to governing so it's it's hard
to make the same distinctions and it's
hard to view these individuals in the
heroic terms that the parties do without
their having to do an awful lot of
revisionism in their history brought a
lot about war and the wars and the
impact of economics which war was the
most or had the most impact on I think
there's no question the Second World War
had the most impact on us and we look at
the post-war political process the
post-war economic system the Second
World War was dramatically important but
there's also no question that every
major war permanently altered the role
in size of government brought about
profound changes in the economic process
there's a tidal wave that comes with a
war no matter what when it's a big war
you mobilize the society you give an
overwhelming share of power to a central
federal government as you have to under
those circumstances and you go deeply
into debt and you struggle to figure out
how you're going to pay for that debt
then when the war is over that tidal
wave ends and you flow back but
throughout our history we never move
back to where we had been before the
federal government always ended up being
a more activist and larger entity and
the tax system and the role that the
government played in the economy
permanently changed that happened with
all the major Wars the Second World War
though
that created a much larger
infrastructure in Washington and because
with its end it really brought with it
the sense that there was a science of
economics and a science of governing
that could be brought to bear really
stays with us why is there a subheading
with the wilbur mills uh if you look at
what makes the 1980s and 90s different
it's actually the 1970s and really if
you look at today and you think about
what's different the notion that we have
debt we have deficits as we've been
talking throughout the course of this
period we've had that always in the past
what makes it different today as much as
anything is the fact that the balance of
the budget the nature of the budget the
rigidity built into the budget has all
changed and it changed very
significantly as a result of the
dynamics of the late 60s and early 70s
where wilbur mills now the late wilbur
mills major figure chairman of the Ways
and Means Committee through a central
period in American history a one-time
presidential candidate undoubtedly one
of the five most significant members of
Congress in the 20th century at least
had more to do with the changes and as
much to do with our fiscal state today
as anybody I believe including Ronald
Reagan did you know him yes I did I got
to know him much better after he left
Congress and of course we will all
recall or many of us plus of us who were
more than twenty will recall in disgrace
uh but after the so-called Fanny Fox
episode with a woman plunging into the
tidal basin after he admitted to having
a great alcohol problem and many other
difficulties but Wilbur Mills became a
major figure in American politics from
Arkansas uh not simply because he gained
in seniority but because he had enormous
talents he had an encyclopedic knowledge
of the tax code
he had a feel for politics and how to
pull majorities together and how to use
the rules of the institution to make
things happen greater than virtually
anybody and in some ways of course what
ended up occurring is the dynamic of the
late 60s Richard Nixon becomes president
a activist Republican very hostile to
Congress facing a Democratic Congress
increasingly liberal they got into a
bidding war to some degree during that
period of time 69 70 71 72 which
revolved around political maneuvering to
see who could be condemned for being
heartless who could be a claimed for
looking out for people much of that
bidding war focused around Social
Security kind of traditional weapon the
Democrats have used against Republicans
as much as anything else we had a yearly
process where you could look at the
Social Security system and from 1969 on
that yearly process where we had for a
long period of time real discipline not
increasing payments very much trying to
keep within a framework of fiscal
discipline suddenly we had huge
increases much outstripping inflation
10% one year fifteen percent the next
year partly because we clearly did have
a problem with real poverty among the
elderly many people who were only able
to subsist on their social security
pensions and it wasn't enough to get by
partly because of this political
maneuvering and as we move closer to
1972 Wilbur Mills decided despite rather
owlish respectable countenance and
anything but a pretty face not a
blow-dried character that he was going
to run for president and he began a
quixotic and a board of campaign that
this was going to be his vehicle and we
saw even greater increases and it was
clearly going to break the fiscal bank
and in that aftermath we indexed social
security to inflation ironically has an
attempt to try and hold down discipline
to to keep these payments from going
completely out of control but the timing
of it was such
that it came just before we had a very
sharp increase in the elderly population
and just before we had a period of huge
double-digit inflation and it created we
indexed all the other entitlement
programs at the time we used a formula
for indexing them to inflation so they
go up automatically not have Congress
have to vote each year that exaggerated
inflation for the elderly to a point
where now just to pick some figures in
1963 the mandatory programs so-called
that include basically these
entitlements as we now refer to them
made up roughly a third or so along with
interest payments of the budget now it's
virtually doubled and the entitlements
per se are about fifty five percent of
the overall federal budget they're on
automatic pilot they continue to go up
there extraordinarily popular with the
American people and they're taking the
flexibility out of our ability to deal
with a budget problem and of course
there's another side to this Brian which
is that back 30 years ago the tax system
had the overwhelming share of revenues
coming in coming from income taxes
personal and corporate income taxes and
the payroll taxes which are basically
the FICA tax that we use to finance
Social Security and Medicare were maybe
a fifth or so about eighteen percent or
so of our overall revenues now income
taxes have moved sharply down as a
percentage and the payroll tax as a
share of the of our revenues has doubled
it's gone up to almost forty percent of
our overall revenues now beginning to
contest income taxes and it's almost as
great as individual income taxes it's
the single largest burden on
three-fourths of American workers and
it's not the best way to tax the system
before we lose time here you have a
section called openness and you write
that the
the openness that has come to politics
and government in Washington is one of
the proudest and those valuable
achievements of the reform movement and
it is here to stay but earlier you say
if voters had not known or seen how
these bargaining processes took place
and had seen only the results they might
not have been happy about them it
there's a lot of unhappiness in town
from time to time about this openness
you think it's good or bad unbalanced
it's better to have it open than not but
we can't get away from it without
recognizing we pay an enormous cost you
know I think when we look at the role of
lobbying question of gifts campaign
monies and the rest we need serious
reform but the single biggest perform
you can have to make sure that you don't
build in a great deal of corruption in a
political process is disclosure sunshine
has an antiseptic effect but let's face
it we have to recognize that the more
disclosure you have the more people are
going to see things that are a natural
advent of a political process the more
disillusioned they're going to become
and what's happened in the last 20 years
or so is great irony in my judgment that
you'd ask almost any historian who's
tracked American politics through 200
years any veteran who's been around
Washington for 30 or 40 or 50 years and
you'd have a consensus that our politics
are cleaner today than they've ever been
you have a consensus in the country at
large that our politics is dirtier and
worse today than it's ever been now how
do you put those two things together
there are many reasons for it but one
reason is that stuff that happened 30 or
40 or 50 years ago money and paper bags
being handed to people alcoholism
philandering that was happening on a
much more regular basis much more
frequently nobody knew about it now
everybody knows about it now every
campaign contribution despite the fact
that they're far more limited than they
used to be and they are disclosed and
they are regulated in a lot of ways that
never occurred before people see them we
get stories every day linking them to
behavior on the
members of Congress adding to the
disillusionment and the sense that the
system is tilted and that it isn't for
real and we've paid a price for it and
the reason that that's in this book
about debt and taxes is that clearly one
of our difficulties here one of our
great dilemmas as a society is that to
solve this kind of a problem requires
pain it's not all in waste fraud and
abuse which means things that other
people get we all have to pay how do we
make that happen you make it happen by
having a political system that can say
to the American people trust us it's
going to hurt now but it's for a greater
good if what people see leads to less
trust and if they don't think the system
is on the up-and-up then you can't make
some of those tough decisions because
the public won't let you they think that
you'll miss use the money and if you
can't make them you get into a spiral
where the disillusionment and cynicism
grow and that's a real problem for us
that somehow we're gonna have to grapple
with and part of the irony is that we
have made a lot of tough decisions that
you had had some real courage on the
part of politicians in the past in the
overall context but they have in part
through their own actions and setting of
expectations set themselves up for a
fall and now one hopes will be in a
position where we can do a little bit
better and begin to get out of this hole
what the book looks like dead in taxes
how America got into its budget mess and
what to do about it co-author our guest
this week Norman Ornstein thank you for
joining us thank you Brian